one of the biggest problems for a finite
minded species I mean let's be honest
we're all we all like to count results
we all like to be see the impact of the
things we're doing and when we're told
we have to do something that will
benefit future generations you know 40
years from now or this won't happen for
50 years but we have to act now you know
a lot of people don't they shrug their
shoulders you know up claim why I lied
to lose you know it's not my problem
right after me comes the flood I won't
be here I think the most important thing
is two things one is we have to change
our own metrics and our metrics should
be about momentum rather than absolutes
especially with things like this which
are infinite in their own respect there
is no winning and losing in the climate
game and I keep saying this which is
we've got the messaging completely wrong
that's the most second part which is the
messaging we've come completely wrong
first of all we called it global warming
sounds appealing it also creates
confusion especially when you have
colder than average winters but I
thought it was warming because people
confuse the climate and the weather the
weather and the climate are not the same
thing we should have called it like a
climate cancer or something because
people react to something like that but
the other thing is is is we keep talking
about we have to save our planet we have
to save our planet
that is actually not true the planet
will be fine the planet will survive no
matter what life will continue with us
or without us what we have to do is save
our species we are affecting the climate
to the point where we will make living
conditions impossible for our species
because we'll need to kill our own food
sources or make it impossible for us to
live because the the the secondary and
tertiary effects of everything that we
do you over fish it kills Carl Hills
lizard all of these things happen that
make it impossible for us it's not it's
not save the planet it's save the human
race and that's what we don't talk about
we because unless you're environmentally
minded so we talk about saving the
planet doesn't appeal to everyone
talking about saving the human race
ensuring that your family will survive
hmm I think that's a much better
messaging so I think we got the
messaging wrong quite frankly so it's
it's it's not about saving the planets
about say
human race in creating a planet that can
sustain human life as monks his life as
everything of everything else that's
that helps us survive to the floor and
fauna included so what is messaging the
other one is how we measure metrics we
want to measure metrics in terms of
momentum
are we moving in the right direction as
opposed to absolutes I think that's very
helpful
[Music]